[Music]
there is no mistake
miss Betty wife she is one of a guy now
mg and now a new documentary is
celebrating Betty's illustrious career
something that we at ET have been so
lucky to be part of work the reason I do
anything is because of my love of
animals she is amazing 96 years old and
cuddling up to a 900 pound grizzly et
has documented Betty's love for wildlife
many times everybody says what would you
do if you weren't in show business what
can you tell what I would do but it was
in our living rooms in front of the TV
where we fell in love with her her
career spans nearly 80 years and along
the way she has been gained for anything
Oh see if we can find her boobs what was
it like going to second base with sandy
she doesn't know what she's saying oh
yes you do you're playing like Betty
White out there that's not what your
girlfriend says a new PBS documentary
better reveals is her stage fright ooh
that helps bring out her best it's
uncomfortable but it's a life saver
the stage fight is what puts the edge I
think on a performance I didn't know
what Facebook was and now that I do know
what it is I have to say it sounds like
a huge waste of time yeah I can't
believe that he did
SNL at that age and and and not only
have S&L age but took the ball and not
get so far with the park and her timing
just rock-solid still what is your last
name ma'am
blonde finger can you spell that for me
yes M
[Music]